can you describe it's full no start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky why
are you I gotta leave a day early
[Music]
your husband's here let me see him he's
extremely ill you have to tell me why
why is what he was doing it was his
decision to go in it's something they
termed the shimmer they've sent in
drones in teams of people but nothing
comes back but something has you're a
biologist who served in the military if
I knew what happened I could save his
life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking cities States
you need to know what's inside it's
beautiful check this out
looks like they're stuck in a continuous
rotation I understand they're no
sharks have take like that not possible
you can't cross great difference babies
chorus the soldiers on the last
expedition went crazy or something in
here kill them
something's come through the fence there
were the fence we have to go back I
can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroying
it's making something new
[Music]
you
you